tonight on live at the Apollo it's Lucy
and age as we're here at the U Nintendo
switch UK premiere a bit hands-on with
the console ver mostly Zelda Zelda we
spent a good 40 minutes between us I put
the first 20 minutes of the game
playable and we brought in slightly
different things to do first of all how
do you find it what did you do so I
followed like the main questline link
wakes up its 100 years later you meet a
weird old man which in any of the game
would probably be a little bit confusing
because also in real life don't mean we
don't do that don't fall asleep for a
hundred years in the old man you get
your own your tablet Shootist roof a
stone I have announced that and that sir
just like your your map your waypoints
and then but the first major thing I did
is I waked in these towers and I think
that's a name for up to the game you
need to awaken all these towers to
destroy the Grand curse that's plaguing
the grandpa tears its calamity Gannon
calamity gana which is an excellent name
for like a dog man yes sounds like from
the Wild West yeah kalama began improve
then woke up found a stick that's like
the first rapper you get you need to
harvest all your weapons now for me the
killing enemies finding the world I find
like a woodcutter's axe or just like
branches and stuff which I found very
interesting just having to live off the
land when it comes to both my weapons my
friend all my resources its most viable
all those although for me though the
annoying part about that aspect of
gameplay is that your weapons
particularly things like the branches
and clubs will break yeah and if you're
made by that can be quite stressful yeah
it's almost got some like witches styled
rep if you're going into a big fight you
need to like okay I need a few weapons I
need a couple of this I need a couple of
that and then you can't like expand your
options and improve your weapons for one
fan fingered on his like if you find the
Master Sword surely that thing isn't
gonna break in a few hits let's go
there's got to be some weapons that you
can keep throughout the game ya the
minute all I've had is like basic bone
club sticks and rush the axes speaking
of that prep which got a fantasy 15 s
good home-cooked meals
we'll set you up for a successful
treasure hunt and you can't you have to
discover the recipes for yourself
because you gather all the resources
like you find apples and mushrooms bits
of meat weird little like fits on board
and stuff to fall off enemies and you
can kind of experiment with what works
what doesn't sometimes we make just
punches and poison yeah oh it's been
five minutes eat in that I kill myself
we know I mean for the first 20 minutes
obviously you can't really dig your dig
as deep as you want overall how did you
find it and have you played on wii u and
what are the main get a difference i
played on wii u 83 actually the wii
version was smoother i add a few moments
where there was frame drop my Ken's
aiming with the enjoy calm controller it
was very difficult I didn't experience
that I use the Wii U gamepad it was a
lot for stable I don't know if it's just
because it's bigger I mean I found there
was a lot of texture pop-in I'm going to
be textured issues but you know they'll
back they are still saying this is
prototype bailed when the textures you
buy a puppet it does look beautiful I
said we were first grown-ups like
playing in the studio ghibli game
exactly so it looks very pretty and you
just have to wait for the textures to
arrive yeah I'm excited there is a lot
of potential there um I'm just looking
forward to playing more than the first
20 minutes short on twice now yeah yeah
feel like I know it off by heart now
yeah for more on the legend of zelda
breadth of the world make sure you keep
those eyes peeled gamespot com
[Music]